[Music]
it was the dawn of 1863 and London's not
yet opened subway system the first of
its kind in the world had the city in an
uproar digging a hole under the city and
putting a railroad in it seemed the
stuff of dreams pub drinkers scoffed at
the idea and a local Minister accused
the Railway Company of trying to break
into hell most people simply thought the
project which cost more than 100 million
dollars in today's money would never
work but it did On January 10th 1863
30,000 people ventured underground to
travel on the world's first subway on a
four mile stretch of wine in London
after three years of construction and a
few setbacks the Metropolitan Railway
was ready for business the city's
officials were much relieved
they'd been desperate to find a way to
reduce the terrible congestion on the
roads London at the time the world's
largest and most prosperous city was in
a permanent state of gridlock with carts
costermongers cows and commuters jamming
the roads it had been a Victorian
visionary Charles Pearson who first
thought of putting railways under the
ground
he'd lobbied for underground trains
throughout the 1840s but opponents
thought the idea was impractical since
the railroads at the time only had short
tunnels under hills how could you get a
railway through the center of a city the
answer was a simple system called cut
and cover workers had to dig a huge
trench construct a tunnel out of brick
archways and then refill the hole over
the newly built tunnel because this was
disruptive and required the demolition
of buildings above the tunnels most of
the line went under existing roads of
course there were accidents on one
occasion a heavy rainstorm flooded the
nearby sewers and burst through the
excavation delaying the project by
several months but as soon as the
Metropolitan Railway opened
Londoners rushed in to ride the new
trains the Metropolitan quickly became a
vital part of
London's transport system additional
lines were soon built and new suburbs
grew around the stations big department
stores opens next to the railroad and
the railway company even created
attractions like a 30-story Ferris wheel
in Earls Court to bring in tourists by
train within 30 years London subway
system covered 80 kilometres with lines
in the center of town running in tunnels
and suburban trains operating on the
surface often on embankments but London
was still growing and everyone wanted to
be connected to the system by the late
1880s the city had become too dense with
buildings sewers and electric cables for
the cut and cover technique so a new
system had to be devised using a machine
called the great head shield a team of
just 12 workers could bore through the
earth carving deep underground tunnels
through the London clay these new lines
called tubes were at varying depths but
usually about 25 metres deeper than the
cut and cover lines this meant their
construction didn't disturb the surface
and it was possible to dig under
buildings the first tube line the city
and South London opened in 1890 and
proved so successful that half a dozen
more lines were built in the next 20
years this clever new technology was
even used to burrow several lines under
London's River the Thames by the early
20th century
Budapest Berlin Paris and New York had
all built subways of their own and today
with more than 160 cities in 55
countries using underground rails to
combat congestion we can thank Charles
Pearson and the Metropolitan Railway for
getting us started on the right track
when we make lessons about the
innovations that have changed the world
we often wonder what's next which one of
our young subscribers will invent
something that will make the world a
better place and how can we help make
space for those ideas to be heard that's
where our student voice initiative
ted-ed clubs comes in whether inventing
ways to recycle
IRA foam or detect silent heart attacks
young people around the world are
brimming with brilliant ideas visit ed
ted.com slash clubs to learn more about
developing and sharing student ideas on
the ted platform
[Music]